like this is like Christmas I'll
turn call to order
the a work session a regular meeting of
the special committee on the Family
Division of the Circuit Court of the
state of Hampshire and the purpose for
this meeting is to go over the interim
report which we have been reading and
I'd like to go through it Page by page
and see if there's any suggested
changes I know there's a few
punctuation things but as we can bring
those up too I'm sure the
um researcher will catch those anyway
but for those of us who are grammatical
fuss Parts it gives us a chance to talk
on them uh page one
memorandum it says if you have any
questions or comments regarding this
report please do not hesitate to contact
me who is
me you because it says from chairman
Pearson it's you it's me okay yeah
because it says from representative
Pearson chairman well that'll do it won
it um the only other thing that I see is
near the bottom there's a couple of
extra spaces
before the name Christen Grant I'm sure
that'll be cleaned up and editing the
drums are supposed to
roll you have been in this AUST body a
lot longer than me and know many things
I don't thank
you how do you get that into the report
a little Emoji we don't do that oh we
don't it's the space anything on the
first page anyone else no okay first
page is done I have a suggestion on that
second
we are turning to the second page
representative Greg I suggest that
representative deimon while an esteemed
colleague be taken off this list since
she was not here and that I would
actually like my name to be
added without objection thank you um I
would
suggest that at least some of the second
page looks to me like it was in the
speaker's setting up of this m uh could
that be flagged
accordingly
just does say charge speak okay charge
and study
purpose
um I just like specifically the Speaker
of The house's name there so people will
know the front page is me and now
suddenly we're on the second page and I
think there should be an acknowledgement
this is his charge to us would it be
like an according to well I think it'
just be speaker Packards charge and
study purpose sure speaker
Packards
yeah and where does that
end I don't have the document study
purpose right okay then you have next
paragraph or next section process and
procedures okay yeah yeah got it any
other changes we might want to suggest
on page
two looks
good page
three
anyone um I have a few things on page
three so um this first part let's gang
up together against problems and not
gang up against each other it's also
repeated on page four um so which page
do we want to leave it on because we
don't want to say that twice on
consecutive page what I think you did
was you took my final note and conflated
it into the intro which is good but that
means repetition may want to go out so
uh where do you want the gang up quote
to be on the top of three or the bottom
of
four I prefer it on the bottom of four
okay so let's take it out so we'll take
out starting at representative pearon
and all the way uh line four on the top
of three line four and five is out got
it and then
um uh the next paragraph the word as
should be stricken and evidence should
be capitalized because it ends with a
just that we received it but no action
it's a separate sentence that starts the
action right agreed I yeah
linguistically paragraph 2 two line two
strike the word as capitalize e for
evidence and then at the end of the
paragraph um the in addition to received
testimony should be stricken it just we
talked about receiving testimony in the
beginning of it but it's confusing
because it sounds as if we received
testimony at the court which we didn't
and I wouldn't want somebody to think
that we had somehow received testimony
testimon members also visit to observe
day-to-day proceed
and proceedings and
procedures period after
proced good let's keep going um on the
paragraph that starts the plan
um is it true that on November 9th a
full committee work session was cons
convened to report on the interim
findings or is that really what we're
doing today or is it both or
what um what did did we do last week no
we did meet on the
N yeah we
did every chair I did yeah I think
that's good there okay um I do think
though where it says additionally
um that that sentence doesn't make a lot
of sense it perhaps if it's said
additionally to consider if there would
be additional subcommittees formed would
make more sense yeah otherwise it sounds
like it's a question additional would
you read your your suggested change
additionally to consider if there would
would be also take out would there be
additional sub committees so just get
rid of the word word there and just say
add in to consider if there okay got
that after
additionally
additionally anything else on three um
stakeholder should be one word in the
next paragraph
y yes yep and then the final paragraph
um I think should be stricken because we
already talked about in the middle at
forming these four subcommittees and
it's uh confusing to talk about forming
the subcommittees again we just said up
here we formed them I
ker what do you like I mean I'm really
trying to tell everybody what a great
job we're doing here together and you
know short of an attached CD with the
choir singing Kumbaya I appreciate that
but knowing the lack of how much people
want to
read so so the thought is the last
paragraph is stricken stricken from the
record me notwithstanding yeah okay all
right kick it out our Hope was not in
vain I mean come on this is good 19th
century flowery language here all right
strike the last paragraph I'll get over
it
and then this page four yeah so instead
of two of them say two of the sub yes I
get after people for doing that too and
then you don't need a comma after Rules
of Evidence just Rules of Evidence and
forms well we
do two of them two of the subcommittees
comma Rules of Evidence and see it could
sound like Rules of Evidence and forms
that's one well there are two the and
yes it is indeed the and is your brain
it's pounded into my head for two years
Oxford
commas um I think the the the forms
should have the the longer title to it
if we're going to mention it at
all do you we
[Music]
could court forms court forms how about
court forms forms two two of the the
subcommittees comma Rules of Evidence
comma and court forms court forms
yeah
comma is it member or is it members of
the two committees Rules of Evidence
andt forms believe their formal work
because it's not the committee it's who
believe it's the members who believe
whether the word committee is is
substantive for the the whole it could
be
but I'm thank
you
address if you want to leave what you've
written that representative Greg as as a
gift for not being acknowledged earlier
yeah
because we'll probably be done pretty
quick I mean we got to had a steam up
here oh dear we uh lose a
quarum unless you come back to vote well
we don't have to vote do we have to
vote I thought we didn't that was the
whole purpose of coming no we clerk
Smith said we had to that was the whole
purpose of having a
forum how soon do you think you'll be
back
accept additional
changes let me Charlie's on his way
because he was supposed to come you had
said that you you had a conflict and it
was Charlie who was supposed to be here
to make our Quorum so let me call him
Charlie is in Boston oh
on the MTA oh no okay I hope he's having
a good time yeah I hope he returns you
kiding about this is a motion you're
making I would like to uh move that the
special committee on the Family Division
of the Circuit
Court um approves
um the inter the
memorandum dated no 16 to go to the
speaker with the understanding that
there will be
um certain tical
changes changes necessary before the
finalu okay we have a motion with is
there a second yes there is and all in
favor I opposed it is so have
fun do you need this I can take pictures
of what you you take that okay and I'll
give it to you later
okay mention in today's exciting episode
the role of Deborah D Simone is now
being able filled by Alicia Greg and the
role of marjerie Smith is as well in
today's episode yes a lot of
personalities going here I got this um
that doesn't go in the report anything
on page
five there's one problem at least in
paragraph three I refer to myself in the
third person and in the first person in
the same paragraph and since I sign the
report at the end if if I'm going to be
um sort of L dah it should at least be
consistent yeah just be the chairman so
I suggest in the third
paragraph first line um you can just get
rid of the word I and did this four
times just get rid of the word I and did
that yeah you just take out I had been
given a copy of of it is um chman person
have been given that's fine just take
out I yeah and did this four times and
it then it all flows quite
well or just add the word the chairman
take out okay I can't really hear much
of anybody I'm sorry bad ears um just
this one word if you get rid of it and
we can take that out but I'm thinking
that in the first line chairman Pearson
becomes I because I signed this
report
so do we want to do that so I I think
you should stay stick with chairman
Pearson because people don't want to
read the whole thing and go okay who is
this like that did this and go to so
they don't have to read to the end
before should to that okay I can live
with that fine speak in the and then
also the word he but we're going to take
the word I out of the end of that third
paragraph uh sometimes even reading the
cases referred to in the footnote not
and this was done four times I mean
taking the word out I out and did this
four it is near you could add take out I
and put the chairman and the chairman
did this four times okay all
right and I don't bring this everywhere
I go but it just seems that way it's a
great
book anybody anything else on that first
page of rules of
evidence um are we going to continue
with pagination at the bottom of the
page we get up to okay so that's page
five anything
else next page page six
anything page
seven
okay page eight which is subcommittee
work oh I have
changed so the first one is uh that I
have and there's probably more but on
that first main paragraph uh one two
three fourth line down requests for
proposals there should be an S at the
end of proposal it says request for
proposal it should be s i I'm sorry
would you speak louder would you speak
closer to the a problem that first
paragraph We Revisited judge Susan
Ashley's testimony on the fourth line
there's a request for of acquiring
requests for proposal it should have an
S it should be plural request for
proposals requests
plural no it's a request for multiple
proposals so where does where do you
after which word do you want the S
proposals okay yeah so an S after
proposal I also think the title should
just be court form subcommittee and
strike the rest in all the quotes
because all the others are just like the
name of the sub it did have a title I
don't know where it went it was a title
on top of it but it was above this but
then I just did to kind of explain it
but yeah this is just taken straight
from our our charge but we can take that
out for sure but it did just have court
forms on the email I think do we want to
abbreviate the title to court forms yeah
we could do that anybody anybody yeah
court forms and maybe capital f forms or
not yeah yeah it should be all right now
I would like the subcommittee chair to
be above my name okay I'm just a member
of that group I want representative
Alicia Greg subcommittee chair to be the
first person mentioned
okay
that first paragraph court forms to be
consistent we would want to have court
capitalized as it is
above uh such as should not be a
semicolon but a
colon did you want to add in you had
mentioned that you were going to be
checking in with the court to make sure
that the work was completed and all was
well um did you want to add something in
here to that effect that way we're just
noting that we don't need to meet any
more but well so that's the part where I
said they they agreed to keep the lines
of communication open for future
conversations as we hear so I kind of
addressed that okay all right that's
fine that was a question I recall I
asked uh the court people present and
they didn't just sort of agree they were
enthusiastic about it they wanted us to
yeah so anything from you or from
representative Smith's no she didn't
have anything okay page nine judicial
training education supervision
accountability so we should put uh
Smith's name first as a chair uhhuh
Y and capitalize
chair and we can I think we can take out
in the title the words draft
11123 y
um and add the word subcommittee to make
it consistent with everybody
else and I I I know the researcher will
be doing this but get the
[Music]
um the case size of the type consistent
throughout the
report um and if one sub
committee's headline is all caps they
all should be and if it's caps and lower
case they all should be so the reports
look consistent to each
other I I kind of think that this
sentence should just add in the word all
because otherwise okay I see what you're
pointing to I don't think they do so
even if a judge is familiar with the law
and almost no judges appointed the
Circuit Court are I feel like it kind of
sounds a bit on the offense but if we
just change it to even if a judge is
familiar with
um the law areas of law or something
like cuz we want to remember that the
judges were attorneys before so we don't
want to make it sound like they don't
know anything about the law right it's
the the really the concern is that
they're not always knowing about family
law or every area of law so we could
just do all aspects of the law yeah and
almost no judges appointed to the
Circuit Court are familiar with all
aspects of the law is that so even if a
Jud familiar with all aspects familiar
with all aspects of the law and then we
take out that next the dash and the to I
don't mind the I don't mind it after
that as long as we say we just have to
keep a comma you gotta in it's not a
comma it's a dash because you broke out
that thought with a dash so it should
not end with a comma but with a dash so
yeah that's true so I'm reading that
line two is now the law Dash and almost
no judges appointed to the Circuit Court
are familiar with all aspects of the law
Dash the
application oh I think I put it before
is familiar with all aspects of the law
and then Dash familiar
with all aspects of La okay all
aspects yeah and then Dash okay but the
dash still replaces the comma at the end
of circuit court change the dash to a
comma either I think the dash is that's
fine yeah I don't usually use a dash use
a comma as a thought
braak anything in the next paragraph no
third paragraph I have something okay in
the third paragraph We have relied on
material for multiple sources comma but
particularly
in so this is a TI an article title so
it should have a a quote after
reform Family Justice principles for
Family Justice Reform and Family Justice
Reform comma quote yep um but I'm
challenging the first sentence we have
relied on material from multiple sources
but
particularly Family Justice I think it
should say including from or including
but particularly including no I think
just instead of particularly and just
say including from including Family
Justice including from or or including
including the but including
okay um well you don't need a but so you
just take that out because you're you
would just say we have relied on
material from multiple s multiple
sources um including Family Justice okay
yes you don't need a
butt um Family Justice Reform close
quote published in 2019 by the national
Center for State Court S
period Comm after not comma while direct
quotes who acknowledge the general
thinking is reflected without necessary
attribution period yeah and wall
shouldn't be capitalized lowercase w
what why no you capitalize it because we
had a period after courts it's a period
so while direct quotes is
capital oh this is supposed to be a
period it's a comma a period okay and
anything else on the rest of the page
yes the next so not the next paragraph
but the one after the principles
discussed in there should be a t for
this report o and then also if you go to
the next line development and uh and
family Dynamics child abuse comma and
substance abuse period okay I've lost
where you are okay so the next so
there's this on that first line and the
principles discuss the second line so
this is a um a bunch of thing so after
child abuse there's a comma and there
should be and substance abuse and
substance abuse period period period
yeah period it
okay at the end of that paragraph should
be a period
y
it seems the um then representative oh
I'm sorry I was going to say it seems
like it should be a
semicolon after where it says the
subcommittee questions the basic premise
appropriate and and then these cases
yeah and then it should be a semicolon
because here's all the questions no it's
not a semicolon it's a colon I meant I'm
sorry I wrote colen I'm saying semien
and then those are the questions and
then ref represenative Smith or or I
guess Vice chair Smith has a uh
correction on the second to last
question what about evaluating the logic
of instead of No it should be not
interviewing
not inure on page 10 it's the old insure
Ure to insure insure is life insurance
policies to make sure that it happens as
Ure yes I
agree this is page
10 okay so if nobody has anything in the
first two after insure on that third
paragraph um in order for a judge to
carry out his and then it should be her
not hers his or her judicial
duties honestly it should really be
there no no it should not be there to
carry out their Duty for a judge is not
there a judge is singular there is
plural a judge his her the new way we're
not supposed to say his or
hers so no we're not going to we're not
going to change it to there
please would it be um that last sentence
in that paragraph among theor miad of
benefits or is it Myriad benefits Myriad
benefits
okay
um so I think you know the at the bottom
should be capitalized and maybe we can
bullet these out so that we understand
that that's under the things to consider
yeah each each one of these on the next
page too there's some are capitalized
some or not I think each one of these
bullet points should be capitalized at
the beginning and the bullet points go
all all the way down to this list is not
it stops stop what specific and there's
Extra Spaces there Extra Spaces and some
need a period at theend yeah what's
specific yeah some need periods right
oh um um here's the stylistic manual
thing if we're going to Bullet them out
each point should end with a period not
a semicolon Yes um and we've got uh
commas in there once and nothing there
so uh now if we're going to Bullet Point
these would it not be a a a bad idea
toet point bullet point on the bottom of
page nine when we had a semic colon
excuse me who was looking at each case
the the items on the bottom of nine
should be bullet pointed yeah for
continuity I think that's a good
idea well they it ends in a question
mark because it is a question nope that
one's not bulleted um no but shouldn't
it be nope that one that one is the next
part of the thing
yeah
so uh Vice chair Smith has some a
significant change to one of the bullet
points on that last since now they're
bullet points on the last page of her
report page 11 yeah so on the if
requiring she crossed out mediation and
put neutral case
evaluation and then um would effectively
reduce case load and
therefore therefore the time okay
good and then uh that's it for that well
wait before we leave that if requiring
what do you wish to what does she wish
if requiring neutral case
evaluation if requiring neutral case
would effectively reduce case load and
therefore time that any case is in the
system huh and therefore the time that
any case is in the system therefore for
the time okay yeah yeah it should be a
period yeah oh so it's a comma and then
that line
should yeah so that moves up so there so
don't so take off the capital W on that
in lower case because that's a
continuation no no that's the next thing
that's a different thing what specific
staff should be added to the court yeah
that's totally separate thing okay but
she's saying if requiring neutri they're
they're asking if requiring neutral case
evaluation would effectively reduce case
load and therefore the time that any
cases in the system that makes sense
okay well it's an if then statement so
what should not be capitalized no well
another that's that's no this is an if
then statement if all of this that the
case in it's an if then
statement because you could say if then
what specific staff should be if you put
the word that's for all the training
that's not just for new neutral case
evaluation if requiring neutral case
evaluation and therefore the time that
any case is in the system what now you
have a dangling okay so we need to add
something but it's not the thing that
goes below it um I think it's then what
specific staff should be added to the
court it's an if then statement I think
they go together then what specific stff
should be added to the court with
responsibilities to best manage the
house no CU that's a totally separate
thing because evaluation chrisa just
said that she could ask her because I I
feel like it's the same thought too I
felt like that was one thing so
Christina said that she would ask her to
see what her intent was on that okay
particular thing well I think specific
staff to be added is a broader thing
than just reducing the case load on this
one thing I agree I would I would think
so but since she's the author of this
part I think it would be best for us to
see what her thought process was on that
so we don't construe something that she
was not intending the end therefore is a
parental so we'll pass it along as she
has written it give her the
opportunity yes yeah because Christina
said she'd ask her so I think that's
fair
so on that last line she um uh Vice
chair uh Smith has rather it represents
some of so that first line at the end
instead of te that last word should be t
h thinking of the committee
[Music]
work anything else on
11 this
is oh yeah it should be exclusive yeah
should this list is not
exclusive
meaning that they're other it's not
exclusive yeah good
catch okay anybody else on 11 thank
you
and all right
12 going back to um page two page two
yes okay was representative Caitlin kab
and Lori ball acted as
Clerks to
Representatives yeah yeah put yeah you
we can list katab and ball both as clerk
on page
two thank you and there's another place
where under process and procedures
second paragraph under that special
commit uh excuse me first paragraph
representative Caitlyn katab and Lori
ball acted as
clerks yeah on no process proced see
where we are oh yes process and proced
yep
okay uh Mr D do we have
this on on page on page two the the
third to last paragraph rate under
process and procedures
yeah no we are back to page two for two
changes yeah very second
page um the third to last paragraph
under processes and procedures it should
say
Representatives Caitlyn cab and Lori
ball acted as clerks and then he also
wanted to put at the top comma clerk
like after the
names uh is that what that's arguable
because the speaker didn't make that
appointment that's fine you don't have
to do that so I would say no because
it'll be picked up in when it's
my thing so no the speaker appointed uh
Pearson and Smith and then I in turn
appointed kavan ball so that's
referenced third
from the bottom okay are we can we go to
page last page
12 yeah so um during the first
subcommittee meeting and it should say
on October 17th
2023 and then if if you can add
um uh where it says uh from the
subcommittee and add the word later I do
not know where you are right now later
spoke with judges Ashley lamir and
because I want to make it clear that
they weren't there she later spoke with
them to get this information okay
everybody have that where's that at the
second to last paragraph So during the
first subcommittee meeting on October
17th 2023 oh and later spoke with judge
Judes Ashley okay at the top oh we got
that now yes got that okay at the top
subcommittee please put representative
katab first as the chair of that
subcommittee and I think we take out
interim Report Draft y because the whole
thing is the interim
report so uh representative long was
there as a substitute for uh
representative C tab uh at the chair
position so do we need to note that in
this CU he he presided over the meeting
that she couldn't be at well that would
have to be down in the other paragraph
where it says on October 17 2023 during
the first subcommittee meeting but I
don't know if we need to get that much
into all of that
okay because this is going to carry on
to be all the meetings that we have that
was just our first meeting and is this
the only one of the committee reports
where we just group everybody I just
wanted to be consistent like yeah we did
on all I think on all of them I did not
group it on mine so maybe we should
group
mine yeah I see where everybody else is
grouped um and then do you have I had
included two appendices do you have
those
uh Miss Dyer and I had a conversation
about how thick we wanted the report to
be did we want minutes of all the
meetings did we want every piece of
testimony that was given
verbally uh or via email or um reports
from different agencies and so on and
you know that's going to make one heck
of a thick report I thought that at this
point we simply wanted to give the
speaker an update he's asked me he asked
the chairs of the special committees
about a month ago to meet with him to
give an update this is an update that is
written and as of the end probably of
this calendar year for most of us and I
thought that putting all of that other
stuff in there is way more than he wants
or will read and all the extra reports
for archival
purposes could go when it we make our
final report whenever we're done
um based on that I I just didn't want
him to have to read a summary of what
those appendices say I thought it was
easier to just put in the appendix
because he probably won't bother to look
at them um but if we take out appendix a
and appendix B then that means we would
need to make this longer by summarizing
them and he couldn't I I'm fine doing it
but we would just need to summarize what
does a what was in appendix a and what
was in appendix B if we have a a brief
paragraph summarizing a appendix A and B
yeah you know not long you know four or
five sentences at most then I would
suggest we
strike they provided the information in
appendix B and in the previous paragraph
this information is provided in appendix
a um and and substitute a
summary of what they said was and that
could be footnoted just not or it could
be in the body of the text so the
appendix B part um it's easy to kind of
strike I can just kind of a strike out
the appendix a part but the appendix B
part was a list of several questions
that we asked and I'm not sure that they
could really be summarized because they
were independent questions I think we'd
just have I'd have to kind of copy them
in there they it was a pretty it was a
summary so I I think that um in in
looking at the other reports that we
have in just saying that during the
subcommittee that we asked these
questions or whatever this is just a
summary to kind of update in where we
are I actually don't think you need to
have all of that stuff in here I think
this would suffice if you strike the
appendix a and appendix B I think when
we do a full report that would be
necessary then but since this is just an
update like summary I actually don't
think it's necessary okay so I think in
the first paragraph or the middle par I
guess the middle paragraph there we can
get rid of this information as a p is
provided in appendix a that's
fine um if you want to say that they
just asked the questions and not even
talk about what they were we can just
get rid of they provided the information
in appendex B and then we're done yeah I
think that works for this particular
report especially because this is an
ongoing we're not done with this
particular one so I think this is a good
update it's well written yeah I felt the
need in the um report on Rules of
Evidence to break out some examples
because that was our final report we're
done but yeah if if a subcommittee
continues
on um let's see what even what the
answers to those questions might be and
that would be part of the final report I
would think so yeah she gave us the
answers to the questions but we can put
them in the final I think so I think so
anything else on page 12 I'd only say
one other thing and just for for um to
keep
it un um looking the same as the term we
in particularly we and it should be the
committee it would follow the same way
that you wrote it down here the sub
committee comme down here so will be the
first full paragraph the second line
particularly the committee wanted to
look instead of we okay just for
continuity
yep okay so on that note we have to go
back to the forms
one which is Page what which is Page uh
it's a great question um
one two three four five six seven page 8
so there's we a few times so I believe
it should read whatever we've decided
that sub committee the subc commmittee
rather than we so each time we see we so
there's on that first paragraph We
visited uh second paragraph we get rid
of all the
Wiis um and then as and then on that
third the next paragraph overall we felt
comfortable and then there's
another we as we hear from
constituents and then at the very last
sentence at this time the subcommittee
does not feel the need for future
meetings period for future meetings okay
period just for
consistent thank you and then get rid of
the dash before subcommittee on that
third to last paragraph like it should
just be subcommittee
Dash right
here right
I think when we do the final report um
we can certainly go through for
continuity of style and you know if we
capitalize the court the word Court one
place we should everywhere um I don't
think it is as urgent presently but
because I don't think this report um
will be broadly disseminated I don't
think so anyway I got to talk to the
speaker about that but I think it's
mostly for him and us I mean I think it
takes only a minute to kind of just yeah
let's take let's take a last minute
after we' print out all the are you
making the changes while we're going or
no no okay you're doing it hard copy are
you
yeah
so then after you make the changes will
will we see the report or like what's
the plan
also
you I think that's perfect because you
know when even like for bills they can
always do a a clerical Amendment
afterwards so we we voted on it if she
after she sends it if we have any
clerical grammatical whatever you
can at that point is the is the request
that we would see this committee would
see the changes before it goes to the
speaker or the next item out goes to us
and to the speaker at the same time
what's your pleasure team I'd like to
see it first just to make sure
everything was captured before it goes
well since we're waiting on uh Vice
chair Smith's uh correction or whatever
on that particular paragraph too it
might just be good if we look it up if
we all see it and then it goes because I
think we could say okay once we get it
like within 24 hours it has to go to the
speaker like we need to get any edits in
immediately okay so when we're finished
uh when you're finished making the
changes please send the amended report
to all of us and then we'll have a day
or so to go through it and you can let
um the vice chair know on this and if it
looks good to all of us out the door it
goes
okay the only uh other item of business
I think is we have two
subcommittees and they may meet as the
chairs of those subcommittees choose uh
just alert uh me uh certainly if you
want to meet at a time when your
subcommittee can all gather then
remember it has to be noticed it is a
public meeting so it has to be noticed
and uh in advance enough
time um send that to me I'll make sure
that it gets to the appropriate people
uh special Kay I think right is the
committee assistant is that
right you can't do three things at once
he's talking about noticing the
subcommittees when the subcommittees uh
decide they want to meet they should let
me know in enough time so I can
contact Special K
okay but it's good
uh so I mean if you guys want to meet
before the end of the year fine I might
suggest that because it's going to get
busy how many bills between the House
and Senate I I heard it was last up to
about
1150 and Rising do you want us to
contact you for the subcommittee or do
you want us to to contact Karen directly
to schedule
it me okay and then I'll pass it along
okay um but I really do suggest I
encourage I exhort you do this a while
it's still fresh in your mind and B
despite the runup to holidays um it's
going to get worse in
January so I'd suggest we do that then
we can schedule a meeting a final
meeting of this
committee uh approve the reports from
the two committees we've already decided
we don't want to form any more
committees to start next year uh then we
can give
um Miss Dia enough time to compile all
the appendices and reports and minutes
and things we think should be in the
report um and then schedule a meeting it
shouldn't take long for us to
uh do the final approval and declare
Victory and for a party what about the
DV um part that we had me talked about
last
week what about it uh will we will we be
doing that committee or or requesting
that
committee what did we conclude last
week I'm not sure that we concluded
anything other than most of the members
thought it would be a good idea to to
have a subcommittee on domestic violence
a subcommittee
of of Judiciary children Family Law And
Criminal Justice Criminal Justice okay
that is what is on my wish list to see
if the speaker has changed his mind
because when I brought it up to him he
was not
favorable I tried to make the case that
while there are other
groups
my suggestion to everybody on this
special committee regarding the subject
of domestic
violence please as many of you as wish
send me a couple of paragraphs to help
me make my case to the speaker why there
should be such a committee because
I have to convince
him and I want as many good points
including points we do not share
broadly why he should do this because
he's a reasonable guy if you make the
case he'll do
something so soon as you want to send me
those things I'll give it a week or two
I have a meeting with him next week
after the Chairman's meeting on Tuesday
I'm in his office this made me a good
time
sound
good thank
you any other
business oh so the notes that I took
from last week in addition to or um was
the domestic violence and I don't know
why but I have it written down for child
abuse and child neglect create a
subcommittee for this I think those were
we were talking about when the spring
comes perhaps adding another
subcommittee so that would we would be
doing in the spring just so I but I do
have the domestic violence in there as
well to make recommendation to create a
special committee to address multiple
issues am I correct in assuming last
week we concluded that when the two
subcommittees of this special committee
are done their work and we've approved
their reports we are
done that was the conclusion I thought
we made so we can make recommendations
going forward but
um she cleared if that we have another
year to continue work on the process so
we still have another year of our
committee but only to work on the things
that we had mentioned
before then down here I know but I don't
know where are
possible no this these are my notes from
that
meeting I want to repeat my question
when we're done are we done or are we
not done I I think I'm confused by the
question that you're asking are you
saying that we're this special committee
is done will dissolve it doesn't exist
anymore at the time when we have this
kind of meeting to approve the final
report based on are getting the two
subcommittees that are continuing their
work when they believe they're done
their work they will file their final
reports as subcommittees we will meet to
approve make changes of that and
anything else in the final report and
that's it we are not forming any more
subcommittees we are not doing anything
else that will be the end of this that
should be clear and I believe we agreed
to that last
time yes I think also we talked about as
far as what we were charged to do is
looking into the family courts that this
would obviously we've had
recommendations Spur off off of it from
domestic violence or anything else but
this particular committee this would be
our final these last two would be our
final we could say that in the course of
talking and listening a few other
subjects came up but we think those
should be addressed by other groups
special committees subcommittees
whatever but not by
us yes okay I'm just clarifying what my
notes were from the last time and that's
why I'm was questioning or just
clarifying that representative Smith
clarified that we had another we had an
additional year to continue the work on
this process questioned how much is
needed for the interim report keeping in
mind that a full report will be due in
one
year that does not say we have to keep
finding things to do until next November
comes if we believe we are done with
what we wish to do we are done and the
final report come out in
February there is no mandate to continue
for another
year and if we do not think that we are
the exact venue whereby these other
subjects such as DV should be considered
we won't take that on we will just put
a exhortation in our final report as to
what we think should be
done
yeah okay are we done anything
else then we are adjourned thank
you and uh please thank is she your
cousin Wednesday Adams I mean she was
very good she looks like you you know
that
it's
chrisa well you
wer but you also weren't smiling you
keeping that straight
face